esta celebración del 11 de febrero
siempre es la movilización Popular en
esta Avenida en el app o revolución de
Teherán y hasta estaba llamada hacer aún
más grande como respuesta del sistema a
esas protestas que surgieron en
septiembre después de la muerte o el
asesinato según la interpretación de una
gran parte de la sociedad de esa joven
kurda Max a mini horas después de haber
sido detenida por la policía de laboral
enteran ellos han hecho una movilización
a todos esos sector que no solamente
apoya el régimen sino que también
trabaja con él los han invitado a estar
aquí esto implica maestros estudiantes
funcionarios y lo hacen en mayor número
que en años anteriores también esta es
la primera movilización que se da
Después de la pandemia y se levantaron
las restricciones pero es un momento
También bien importante para ellos en el
que el líder supremo de la Revolución ha
tratado un llamado de la unidad la
ciudad está llena de pancartas que dice
nosotros juntos podemos construir
nosotros juntos podemos aprender
nosotros juntos podemos ser victoriosos
pero la realidad es que lo que se ve en
esta celebraciones solamente un sector
de esa población la mayoría de las
mujeres por ejemplo solamente van
cubiertas con ese echador negro muy
pocas mujeres y si no la única que tiene
el pelo descubierto he sido yo en esta
demostración Y esto no es lo que se ve
en el resto de calles de la ciudad
especialmente de Teherán y no solamente
en el norte sino en otros sectores Así
que esto es un momento que ellos dirán
es un momento victorioso para la
República islámica Pero también es un
momento que es crítico para ellos ayer
se reunía por primera vez en Washington
diferentes personalidades de la
oposición en el extranjero explicando
como se imaginarían ellos un país en el
futuro Así que es un momento de Reto y
más que de Unión como llamarnos líder
supremo se puede mostrar la división que
hay en el país